[Music]
you may take them for granted
but your teeth are a marvel they break
up all your food over the course of your
life while being strong enough to
withstand breakage themselves and
they're formed using only the raw
materials from the food they grind down
in the first place what's behind their
impressive strength teeth rely on an
ingenious structure that makes them both
hard and tough hardness can be thought
of as the ability to resist a crack from
starting while toughness is what stops
the crack from spreading very few
materials have both properties for
instance glass is hard but not tough
while leather is tough but not hard
teeth manage both by having two layers a
hard external cap of enamel made up
almost entirely of a calcium phosphate
and beneath it a tougher layer of dentin
partly formed from organic fibers that
make it flexible this amazing structure
is created by two types of cells a meal
of lasts that secrete enamel and owed on
toe blasts that secrete dentin as they
form teeth owed on togh lasts move
inward while a Miele blasts move out and
slough off when they hit the surface for
enamel this process produces long thin
strands each about 60 nanometers in
diameter that's one one thousandth the
width of a human hair
those are bundled into rods packed
together
tens of thousands per square millimeter
to form the shield like enamel layer
once this process is finished your
enamel can't repair itself again because
all the cells that make it are lost so
we're lucky that enamel can't be easily
destroyed Oh donto blasts use a more
complex process but unlike a miele
blasts they stick around continuing to
secrete dentin throughout your life
despite the differences in teeth across
the mammalian order the underlying
process of tooth growth is the same
whether it's for lions kangaroos
elephants or us what changes is how
nature sculpts the shape of the tooth
altering the folding and growth
patterns to suit the distinct diets of
different species cows have flat molar
teeth with parallel ridges for grinding
tough grasses cats have sharp crested
molars like blades for shearing meat and
sinew pigs have blunt thick ones useful
for crushing hard roots and seeds the
myriad molars of modern mammals can be
traced back to a common form called
tribus Phoenix which first appeared
during the dinosaur age in the 19th
century paleontologist Edward drinker
cope developed the basic model for how
this form evolved he hypothesized that
it started with a cone-like tooth as we
see in many fishes amphibians and
reptiles small cusps were then added so
the tooth had three in a row aligned
front to back and connected by crests
over time the cusps were pushed out of
line to make triangular crowns adjacent
teeth formed a continuous zigzag of
crests for slicing and dicing a low
shelf then formed at the back of each
set of teeth which became a platform for
crushing as cope realized the tribus
FINA cola served as the jumping-off
point for the radiation of specialized
forms to follow each shaped by
evolutionary needs straighten the crests
and remove the shelf and you've got the
conveniently bladed teeth of cats and
dogs
remove the front cusps raise the shelf
and you've got our human molars a few
additional tweaks get you a horse or cow
tooth some details in copes intuitive
hypothesis proved wrong but in the
fossil record there are examples of
teeth that look just as he predicted and
we can trace the molars of all living
mammals back to that primitive form
today the ability to consume diverse
forms of food enables mammals to survive
in habitats ranging from mountain peaks
and ocean depths to rain forests and
deserts so the success of our biological
class is due in no small measure to the
remarkable strength and adaptability of
mammalian molar ted-ed is a non-profit
if you value our work please consider
supporting it on patreon.com slash
ted-ed
[Music]